ciao ma riverso e ben dell'ultimo
nuovissimo
come potete notare sono pronta per il
mio capodanno divano pantofole abbinate
e serie tv ma ovviamente non tutte le
marine saranno a casa capodanno quindi
per coloro che invece usciranno andando
a ballare andranno a cena fuori vorranno
essere al top del dott
ho preparato questo video con 5 outfit
per capodanno
partiamo col botto con il valletta toe
sì perché non c'è capodanno senza
paillettes senza sberluccicanti punti
luce e questo abito di punti luce né a a
josé consiglio questo outfit a tutte
coloro che non amano passare inosservate
a tutte coloro che anche solo per una
notte vogliono sentirsi le regine della
festa le parti girl per eccellenza
perché a capodanno si può usare per chi
a capodanno
tutto è concesso ed ecco a voi il
secondo outfit il dorato ma anche un po
oro nero grazie alla cintura
come potete notare questo outfit molto
dorato ma anche molto arabeggiante per
le jasmine di oggi proprio per questa
sua particolarità
l'ho utilizzato per un mio capodanno
precisamente quello dell'anno scorso che
ho trascorso a dubai in sovraimpressione
potete constatare coi vostri occhi che
utilizzato questo auspicio il mio
capodanno arabeggiante questa è una
delle poche foto che mi ha fatto salvo
in cui sono venuta bene quindi un
applauso salvo
trovo questo outfit pazzesco tant'è che
ho utilizzato molto comodo perché come
potete notare una tutina quindi potete
ballare di menarvi fare anche la danza
del ventre ma senza mai perdere la
classe l'eleganza e loro nei raggi né
che è un nuovo aggettivo
ed ecco a voi il news detto anche il
kardashian detto anche l'etichettatura e
se vi state chiedendo perché ho detto
etichettato beh perché ancora
l'etichetta ovviamente questo
meraviglioso abito l'ho comprato
quest'estate a new york ne sono
innamorato appena l'ho visto però non ho
ancora trovato l'occasione ad arte per
sfoggiarlo ma visto che è così pazzesco
e non me lo ricordavo perché non
indossavo da allora ho pensato che forse
potrà essere proprio lui il mio outfit
per questo capodanno ma non è detta
l'ultima parola perché dal momento che
non so ancora cosa fare a capodanno
magari vado in montagna e forse non è
propriamente adatto ma vi aggiornerò vi
aggiornerò ovviamente su instagram
vedrete tutto l'evolversi della mia
organizzazione last minute di capodanno
e passiamo dunque al pitonato o anche
abbinato perché infatti ho abbinato un
top nero con questa manica molto abba
molto dancing queen
a questo punto non è pitonato di zara mi
raccomando però il pitonato sempre su
stampa perché le pelli degli animali
esotici non vanno assolutamente
utilizzate per creare dei vestiti
esotici e non io sono contro qualsiasi
tipo di sfruttamento di animali vivi o
morti per insomma creare dei vestiti
questo top l'ho preso nello stesso
negozio dove acquistato l'abito news di
prima a new york e della stessa marca ed
è anche questo
etichettato top quindi chissà se
quest'anno capodanno utilizzerò il miur
ha utilizzato il pitonato ritrovo tutti
e due molto molto molto topa d'oro per
un capodanno a livigno forse il nome lo
consiglierei ma se andate alle maldive
in polinesia francese o in madagascar
potrebbe essere la giusta alternativa
per finire in bellezza
ecco a voi l'outfit chiara ferragni
perché l'ho chiamato chiara ferragni
perché i fan
e anche non i fan comunque si
ricorderanno che quando fede ha fatto la
proposta di matrimonio davanti a tutti
all'arena di verona è stato un momento
bellissimo
lei indossava un abito molto simile a
questo di velluto nero con queste
applicazioni che qui sono finti
swarovski magari lei nel suo vestito
erano veri ma tralasciamo questi piccoli
dettagli
il prezzo sicuramente è differente ma
l'effetto è comunque pazzesco perché il
velluto fa sempre festa velluto nero poi
è di un'eleganza estrema questi punti
luce sono adatti a tutte coloro che
amano total black ma capodanno vogliono
osare un periodo di più senza comunque
andare a finire sulle paletto su cose un
po troppo esuberanti quindi consiglio
questo altri da tutte coloro che amano
l'eleganza la raffinatezza chiara
ferragni e soprattutto a tutte coloro
che attendono speranzosi uomo che le
faccio alla proposta di matrimonio
ragazzi c'è qualcuno qui io sono pronta
sono ready
eccoci arrivati purtroppo alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che questi outfit
che vi ho proposto vi siano piaciuti
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
quale avete preferito e soprattutto a
quale vi spire rete per il vostro
capodanno super top come al solito vi
ricordo di iscrivervi al canale se non
l'avete ancora fatto e di cliccare sulla
campanella che trovate vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti i miei nuovi video
ricordatevi inoltre di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social facebook
instagram e tic toc vi mando un bacione
enorme e vi auguro buona
presto d'oro
[Musica]